- Good evening everybody
and welcome to our Seder.
We wanna wish you all a very
happy fourth night of Passover.
This is a holiday that
celebrates transitions.
From confinement to liberation,
from winter to spring,
and aptly, it's a holiday
that celebrates tenacity
and resilience in the times
of overwhelming adversity.
Now normally, our friends
and our loved ones
would gather together on this night
and would tell the ancient story
and even though we are all
pretty much separated tonight,
it seems like this story is more timely
and more important than ever.
So we soldier on.
Even though we can't
physically be together,
we can still eat and laugh
and reflect and dream
and we can do all that while
raising much-needed funds
for the CDC Foundation.
So please during our Seder,
locate that Donate button
and give it a little click.
But first, we sing.
Now this is not just a sit back and relax,
you actually have to recline.
This is a holiday that
celebrates slouching, alright?
So, welcome to our Saturday Night Seder.
♪ We've got a lot to talk about ♪
♪ And even more to eat ♪
♪ Take your shoes off and your coat off ♪
♪ There's there bathroom have a seat ♪
♪ So you're stressed by all the stories ♪
♪ That you hear on Cable News ♪
♪ Well it's time to trade the cable ♪
♪ For a table full of Jews ♪
(clarinet music)
♪ This night is always different ♪
♪ From every other night ♪
♪ There's a smidgen of religion ♪
♪ But we're keeping that part light ♪
♪ Tonight is even stranger ♪
♪ Then the average Pesach meal ♪
♪ 'Cause we're trapped in our apartments ♪
♪ And the plagues are effing real ♪
(upbeat music)
♪ Dayenu Dayenu ♪
♪ Enough's enough's enough ♪
♪ So the world's a bit fakakta ♪
♪ Still we've been through tougher stuff ♪
♪ Dayenu ♪
♪ And truth it's been a lot ♪
♪ But my goodness let's be grateful ♪
♪ For the good things that we've got ♪
♪ Dayenu ♪
♪ What more is there to say ♪
♪ When you can't go out ♪
♪ Get drunk and shout Dayenu anyway ♪
♪ So you need to go out shopping ♪
♪ But it's better not to risk it ♪
♪ Use some fruit snacks for haroset ♪
♪ And beef jerky for the brisket ♪
♪ If you're out of greens and table salt ♪
♪ Well don't you fret my dears ♪
♪ Just use a stick of celery
to wipe away your tears ♪
♪ La, la, la, la ♪
♪ Dayenu ♪
♪ The kids all need a bath ♪
♪ The only thing they
learn in homeschool ♪
♪ Is their father sucks at math ♪
♪ Dayenu ♪
♪ Tonight the food's symbolic ♪
♪ The egg means spring ♪
♪ And all this wine
means I'm an alcoholic ♪
♪ Dayenu ♪
♪ What more is there to say ♪
♪ When life is hell ♪
♪ You gotta yell Dayenu, anyway ♪
(slow dramatic music)
♪ So we invited every
putz and alte kaker ♪
♪ Not to mention every
mancher every makher ♪
♪ To come together as
one glorious Bischplaga ♪
♪ And here to you ending some Bischplaga ♪
- Yes, yes, Josh Groban everyone
the greatest Jewish voice in Zero Mostel.
- Thank you, but I'm actually not Jewish.
- Say what not?
- Yeah, I'm definitely not either.
- You're kidding.
- Yeah, none of us are.
- No way!
- Sorry, are we crashing?
- Should we go, or?
- No, no are you kidding?
We're gonna have a lot of fun,
we're raising money
for the CDC Foundation.
So, we're gonna have stories and sketches,
a lot of laughs and wisdom.
Idina Menzel is going to sing.
- Idina Menzel?
- She alone would be enough.
- Don't you mean.
♪ Dayenu ♪
♪ Yes welcome to our tribe ♪
♪ But listen to the CDC and
stay the (whistles) inside ♪
♪ Dayenu ♪
♪ So the matzah didn't rise ♪
♪ And we're living in a world
we can hardly recognize ♪
♪ What stays constant is this story ♪
♪ And the fact that we'll pull through ♪
♪ So tonight it doesn't matter ♪
♪ If you are or aren't a Jew ♪
♪ Let's remember what we're grateful for ♪
♪ Who we're grateful to ♪
♪ Dayenu ♪
♪ Dayenu Dayenu hey ♪
- For those of you who don't
know what Passover's all about,
congratulations, you
skipped Hebrew school.
- Let's recap Hebrew school real quick.
- My eighth grade is really
Hebrew teacher (mumbles)
came back from the break with a new toupee
and we were not allowed to talk about it.
- Dayenu.
- Rachel Levin came back from summer break
with sticks and bandages on her nose.
Not allowed to talk about it, Dayenu.
- Dayenu.
- There is no worse food
less worth waiting for
than the food at a Seder.
- I don't know 'cause
Gefilte fish is pretty good
if you're a dog.
- Yeah!
- That is terrible.
One time at Seder,
my cousin Libby pulled
me aside in the kitchen
when we were just out of
earshot of my then new boyfriend
and she told me, "You could do better."
And then I tried her tzimmes
and I said, "So could you."
- I still don't know what tzimmes is for,
I think it means something important.
- Oh, Pamela, I like you and I like Jews.
- I like Jews too, Julie.
- Happy Passover everybody (tweets)
- Wash your hand.
- So here we go.
Now, it was suggested to us that
we sing happy birthday twice
while we're washing our hands.
But I was thinking maybe
I would do something else.
So, here it goes.
♪ I was working in a bridal
shop in flushing queens ♪
♪ Till my boyfriend kicked me out ♪
♪ In one of those crushing sinks ♪
♪ Where was I to go ♪
♪ What was I to do ♪
♪ I was out on my fanning ♪
♪ Then over the bridge ♪
♪ And why she did the Sheffield filter ♪
♪ I was in cell makeup
but the butlers are more ♪
♪ I had style I had flat I was there ♪
♪ That's how I became the nanny ♪
Wasn't that fun?
Now my hands are nice and clean
and we can begin with the Seder.
- The first Passover was when
the Jews were still in Egypt.
They were shut up in their
homes, they were anxious,
they were scared, they
didn't know the future
and there was blood on the doorposts.
This Passover is in a way
reminiscent of the very first,
different from any that we have ever
celebrated in our lifetimes.
But remember what happened later,
that Passover gave way to deliverance
and that even though it began in darkness,
it ended in light.
(soft piano music)
- I and a bunch of other people
got together and we ended up
doing this thing called a Memory Feast.
So what we did was we
brought all of this food
and all of this drink, but
each thing that we brought
had to be connected to a specific memory.
And it was just a great experience
to not only be able to share that,
but to feel more connected with them
because they also shared stories,
sweet stories of their own backgrounds
and their own childhoods.
- My younger son reenacts the story
with Playmobil characters
like the Seder is so flexible,
it's such an awesome way
to have a Jewish holiday
where it's based in the home
and it can be creative and fun
with just kind of a loose
structure of 15 things.
It's simple.
- We say (speaks in foreign language)
meaning next year, the year to come.
There's a great song that many
of my friends and family sing
when we gather together
and the main chorus goes
♪ (sings in foreign language) ♪
Meaning, we will see, we will see
just how good it will
be in the year to come
although it may not feel like it now.
The song always is a great reminder
that there are so many good
things that are ahead of us
if only we can hold our hope.
(gentle piano music)
♪ (sings in foreign language) ♪
- Happy Passover, everyone.
(upbeat music)
- Hello, it's the Glazers
with the four cups of wine.
- Well, I don't think...
That is not wine, is it?
- It's a cocktail.
Okay, these are trying times.
- So, this is everyone's
favorite part of the Seder
except from mine.
If the afikoman happens to
be covered in chocolate.
- This is the part we've
all been training for
every night for weeks, drinking.
- But Jews, pace for
yourself, we're not drinkers.
- We have sensitive tummies.
(upbeat music)
- So, a long, long time ago,
our great, great, great
whatevers came to Egypt.
- Now you gotta remember, this
was before Egypt was Egypt,
it was like...
Was Egypt and there was this stuff.
But Joseph figured out
how to save the Egyptians.
- Joseph, one of our forefathers.
- Yup, brilliant man, I'm
talking Einstein brilliant.
Big on dreams, big on flamboyant codes
and Jesus said, "God, people I love them."
- But then, He died.
- He died.
- Yeah.
- And then there was this new Pharaoh
who didn't know Joseph.
He didn't know Joseph from Adam.
And he looked around this country,
he's like, "Well, hold on a second.
"Hold on, wait, what are
all these Jews doing here?"
- Yeah, and hating Jews wasn't
a cliche then back then.
This was unbelieved or
not wildly original.
- Yeah, back then to
hate Jews, you are really
at the vanguard of culture.
- So, Pharaoh said, "I hate
these Jews, let's enslave them!"
So, things changed to the horrible.
- Imagine hearing the most
beautiful song that ever was
then being told, you're never
gonna hear that song again.
- And what's more, you're forbidden
from singing it yourself.
You know it exists
because you heard it once.
- To never hear it again.
This is the most beautiful
song in the world.
- And you have to live knowing it exists
for others to enjoy, but not you.
♪ Some day I wish upon
a star and wake up ♪
♪ Where the clouds and far behind me ♪
♪ Where troubles melt like lemon drops ♪
♪ Up way above the chimney tops ♪
♪ That's where you'll find me ♪
- At the end of the 19th century,
a blistering period of
violence known as the pogroms,
caused thousands upon
thousands of European Jews
to seek refuge in America,
embarking on an Exodus of their own.
Millennia after their
departure from Egypt,
Jews hastily packed, huddled together,
and crossed an endless sea
in an effort to find a better life
in a land they had only
imagined in lullabies.
♪ When all the world is
our hopeless jumble ♪
♪ And the rain drops tumble all around ♪
♪ Heaven opens all magic rains ♪
♪ When all the clouds darken up ♪
♪ The sky wave is a rainbow
highway to be found ♪
♪ Meeting from your window pane ♪
♪ To a place behind the sun ♪
♪ Just a step behind the rain ♪
- Two children of those
storm tossed immigrants,
Harold Arlen, born Hyman
Arluck to Lithuanian Cantor
and Yip Harburg, born Isidore Hochberg
to Yiddish-speaking Russians
reached deep into their
immigrant Jewish consciousness
to write an unforgettable
melody set to near
prophetic words, "The Wizard of Oz"
opened New Year's Day in 1939,
less than two months after Kristallnacht,
a night that saw Jewish businesses looted
and synagogues burned by the Nazis.
Here are the lyrics in this context
and suddenly, the words are no
longer about wizards and us,
but about Jewish survivor.
♪ Somewhere over the rainbow ♪
♪ Way up high ♪
♪ There's a land that I heard of ♪
♪ Once in a lullaby ♪
♪ Somewhere over the rainbow ♪
♪ Skies are blue ♪
♪ And the dreams that you dare to dream ♪
♪ Really do come true ♪
♪ Someday I wish upon a star ♪
♪ And wake up where the
clouds are far behind me ♪
♪ Where troubles melt like lemon drops ♪
♪ Away above the chimney tops ♪
♪ That's where you'll find me ♪
♪ Somewhere over the rainbow ♪
♪ Bluebirds fly ♪
♪ Birds fly over the rainbow why ♪
♪ Then oh why can't I ♪
- Throughout his career, lyricist Harburg
continued to write about
justice and liberation,
not for just Jews, but
for all oppressed people.
He said, "The Passover Seder
"is devoted entirely to
the fight for freedom."
The Jews being a minority,
have always known
that if anyone is enslaved
anywhere, it too is their fight.
Their songwriting was beautiful, yes,
but also urgently political.
In the words of composer
Arlen, music doesn't argue,
discuss or quarrel, it simply
breathes the air of freedom.
♪ Someday I'll wish upon a star ♪
♪ And wake up where the
clouds are far behind me ♪
♪ Where troubles melt like lemon drops ♪
♪ Away above the chimney tops ♪
♪ That's where you'll find me ♪
♪ Somewhere over the rainbow ♪
♪ Bluebirds fly ♪
♪ Birds fly over the rainbow ♪
♪ Why then why can't I ♪
♪ If happy little bluebirds fly ♪
♪ Beyond the rainbow ♪
♪ Why oh why can't I ♪
(whimsical piano music)
- Good evening from Harlem
friends and happy Passover.
I'm Amichai Lau-Lavie and I've been asked
to give some Rabbinic interpretation about
the gastro Judaic mystical,
meaning of this Passover night.
We have this thing called a
Seder Plate, it's a Mandala,
a centerpiece that has the
essential foods of the night,
each of them, a portal
into mysterious meaning.
For instance, the matzah
is bread of poverty,
what slaves ate back in Egypt,
a memory of our worst moment,
but also the first flavor
when we crossed the threshold
into freedom, autonomy and slavery,
the paradox when you bite into the matzah
that's on the plate.
You've got a big cup 'cause drinking helps
open the heart and be a little more free.
You've got this thing, I
know what you're thinking.
Horseradish (speaks in
foreign language) bitterness.
You eat this to cry,
to physically embody the
memories of oppression.
And then there's this, made
it last night, haroset,
mortar, fruit, nuts,
wine, cinnamon, delicious.
But this was the mortar with
which our ancestors built
the walls of their own oppression.
We put things on the Seder Plate
like eggs and vegetables to
eat, to remember, to unite
into the deeper meaning
of liberation, personal
and collective in every moment.
(upbeat music)
- Hey, what's up.
I'm Mike Solomonov and I'm the chef
and co-owner of Zahav
Restaurant in Philadelphia.
- And I'm Dan Levy and I can't get a table
at Zahav Restaurant in Philadelphia.
- How's your Passover, Dan Levy?
- This is the first time
I've brushed my hair
in about two and a half
weeks and it's not great.
- I'm here to help you
with your Seder Plate.
All right, listen, we need a bone.
I've got a chicken bone here,
you need something that
resembles a Paschal Lamb.
- This is a dog treat, I
mean it's a bone for my dog.
So, this is gonna have to do.
- Levy, do you have something
that would resemble mortar?
Something like Jammy, something sweet?
- I have a pair of butter
that I got in the gift bag.
Could that work?
- That'll work, and now you
don't have to re-gift it either.
Next, we need something that's like
lettuce or something green.
I use romaine like baby romaine.
- What does salsa verde do?
- Yeah, that's great salsa verde works.
- I have some pickles.
- Pickle, yes and then an
egg, we need a roasted egg.
- Okay, this used to be a lemon.
- Go forward.
And then you're missing one
vegetable that evokes spring.
- This is off of a decorative
plant that's up on the yard.
- So put that down in between
the egg and the salsa verde.
You have just completed a Seder Plate.
- Thank you so much, I will set it aside
for the zero guests that will
be coming over for the Seder.
- Don't forget the matzah.
(upbeat music)
- Hey everybody, I'm Andy
Cohen and I'm gonna lead you
through what is my favorite
part of Passover, and no,
it is not fighting with your
uncle when he uses the phrase,
those people although
that's a close second.
I mean The Afikoman
So, it is a tradition to
hide a piece of matzah
somewhere for someone to find.
And tonight, that someone is all of you
and you're about to find
out where that somewhere is
because it's time to play a
game that we're calling...
Okay, I guess we are
really calling it this,
Find The Aficohen.
Here's the clue,
The Afikoman is hidden
on a website somewhere
on her majesty's internet,
www dot a phrase that has to do
with passover, dot com.
Wow, that is really
specific, did you get it yet?
The phrase has to do
with the opening number.
It's a really big mystery, huge.
Good luck, and if you need me,
I'll be here in my apartment
like all of us because the whole world
has become literal real housewives.
See you soon.
(tintinnabulation)
- So, I'd say my favorite
thing about being a Jew
is controlling the banks and the media.
But besides that, I really
like it's a culture of
questioning and I like all the
questions that surround this.
And I think the four
questions are probably
my favorite part of Passover.
And usually, the youngest
in the family ask
those four questions.
I used to be the youngest
and so I would ask them,
but now that I'm no longer the youngest,
I thought it would be cool
to bring in my youngest son
to come in and maybe do
the four questions himself.
- Hi Nick, how's the going?
- Good Finn, how are you son?
- I'm good, you gotta
stop calling me your son.
- Okay, can I say that I'm your
co-star in stranger things.
- It won't be true, but
yeah, you could do that.
- Okay, great.
So are you ready to
sing our four questions?
- Ah, I don't think so.
I mean, I don't even
know the four questions.
- Well look, I don't actually
know them very well myself,
I just used to sing "Hakuna Matata"
and then my grandfather
would cry in embarrassment.
So, I--
- Guys, this is embarrassing,
you've to let me help you.
- Oh, a piano?
- Always.
- Cool yeah, you're not
the youngest though.
- I can log off, kid.
(gentle piano music)
♪ (sings in foreign language) ♪
Happy Pesach, everybody,
that's the way it's done.
Mic drop, I'm out. (laughs)
(claps) (tweets)
(upbeat music)
- Why is this night different
from every other night?
Great question, Edina,
it's beautifully asked.
So, matzah, herbs, cushions,
dipping, why tonight?
- The answers are very
intense if you are high.
So, glass two or excuse yourself
to go bath in the bathroom.
- A sweet taste of Manischewitz,
Oakey nodes of Hawaiian punch.
- Hello, hater of later Seder.
It is I, Joshua Malina with
a very early Kol Nidre appeal
on behalf of the CDC Foundation.
The CDC Foundation is, as
today's kids like to say, the
(beep)
It is a non-partisan,
non-profit foundation
that does everything it can to
fight the COVID-19 pandemic.
They provide protection,
they provide detection,
they provide PPEs and emergency workers.
So, it's a very worthy cause
and I urge you to dig deep.
Why not give high or twice high,
maybe even 10 times
high big shot, why not?
Give till it hurts.
We're here trying to raise money
for a very good organization.
So, thanks for taking
part in tonight's Seder
and give some tzedakah.
Mother (bleeps)
(gentle piano music)
- Every year, about an hour or
two before the guests arrive
for our beautiful Seder
and the smell of delicious (mumbles)
food wallowing through the house.
- I would embarrass my little brother
during the four questions
and make him laugh.
He was an (beep) deserved it.
- Something about Passover
that I often think about is Gefilte Fish.
I don't understand it and I
don't understand the smell.
I don't understand why people
would prefer to eat that
in any circumstance later on holiday.
- I would always hear my mother say,
"This is the last year I'm doing this.
"Every God damn year I worked so hard
"and no one appreciates
it, do you understand?
"I'm done, so enjoy the Seder of this year
"because it's the last
time I will work like this
"with no one, no one giving a (beep)
"Do you understand?
"Oh God, I don't even know why I bother.
"Get done, guests are here."
(upbeat music)
- Hi, we're back.
Way back.
- Way back in Egypt land.
♪ Way back in Egypt land ♪
Anyway, the Pharaoh has
made all the Jews slaves.
They are now the victims of
the original pyramid scheme.
- But, oh boy.
It was a great time to be Egyptian.
- Welcome to ancient Egypt,
it's the year 1400BC.
So, we are way before Christ,
but we are definitely mid-party.
We've got dancing, We've
got grapes, we've got
big huge leaves to fan you with
while you cruise on a barge.
It's like Palm beach but
with less tennis, more clubs.
We've invented toothpaste, people.
In Mesopotamia, they haven't
even invented teeth yet.
(laughs)
And here we are, doing all
of that with hieroglyphics.
That's right, hieroglyphics.
Also The Nile isn't just a river,
it's a top notch tourist attraction.
A perfect place to catch a sunset
or find a baby in a basket.
But our biggest claim
to fame are pyramids,
are great and glorious pyramids.
Thousands of years from now,
people will come from all
over the world and they'll go,
"Huh, I thought it'd be taller."
- Okay, first of all, pyramids,
no, we're not doing that.
Pyramids are canceled.
We have a whole horizon,
you think you're gonna be the only shape?
I don't think so.
Triangles, triangles, triangles.
You think you invented triangles?
Yeah, why don't you ask Larry Kramer?
You think ancient Egypt
happened before the AIDS crisis?
Yes, I'm reading the script.
I'm not Jesse Tyler Ferguson,
I don't have those chops.
Let's see, all day it's torture.
The (bleeps) sun shining on me.
I'll have melanoma by the time
I'm 24 and will die at 27,
sounds a lot like, oh, you
know what, the AIDS crisis.
Oh, right, Virtual Seder.
Well, my career is going real well.
I know there's like a sub-urban
mom in Indiana right now
watching this with her
14 year old daughter
who loves Broadway and
thinks I'm a little much.
Well, hang in there
because in two minutes,
you've got Henry Winkler
and then all will be okay.
We need a savior, someone
who can help, save us.
We need someone mighty and brave
who will come along and save us and fast.
- Thank you Billy, you never disappoint.
So 5,000 plus years ago,
the Jews were without
leadership until finally,
Moses arrived to liberate
them from slavery.
And do you know what Moses said
when God found Moses feeding his goats
and asked him to go back to
Egypt to free the slaves?
Moses said, "Whoa, whoa, whoa,
"wait a minute, why me?
"oh, no, why me?
"Why would I do such a thing?
"How could you even think
I could do such a thing?"
Moses didn't feel worthy of the task.
He was slow of speech, slow of tongue.
"Please Lord, ask anybody else."
But there was a need,
too much suffering to ignore,
too much work to be done.
So in a time of crisis, Moses,
the most unlikely of leaders,
stepped up to the plate.
And do you know what?
We all have that power.
Every one of you who is sitting at their
Passover table right now.
Some of you know you have your pound,
some of you have tasted it,
some of you don't know it's there.
You must go on a search for
it because when the time
is right, when the need is there,
you can all step up to the plate.
So with a racing heart, Moses
goes to Pharaoh with a plane.
♪ When Israel was in Egypt's land ♪
♪ Let My people go ♪
♪ Oppressed so hard they could not stay ♪
♪ Go down Moses ♪
♪ Way down in Egypt's land ♪
♪ Tell old Pharaoh ♪
♪ Let My people go ♪
- But Pharaoh would not
listen, so the plagues began.
First, the water of the
Nile ran red with blood.
Then Egypt teamed with frogs
and lice and wild animals.
Livestock fell ill.
And painful boils
covering everyone's skin.
♪ So Moses went to Egypt's land ♪
♪ Let My people go ♪
♪ To make old Pharaoh understand ♪
♪ Go down Moses ♪
♪ Way down in Egypt's land ♪
♪ Tell old Pharaoh ♪
♪ Let My people go ♪
- And each time a new plague began,
Pharaoh would promise
to liberate the Jews.
Yet no sooner had the
Lord ended the plague
than Pharaoh's heart would harden,
and he would not keep his word
and he did not free the slaves.
So, the Lord sent a hail of fire,
a swarm of locusts, an endless darkness,
the worst darkness where no
one could see their neighbor.
And finally, the tenth plague.
♪ Thus spake the Lord bold Moses said ♪
♪ Let My people go ♪
♪ If not I'll strike your firstborn dead ♪
♪ Go down Moses ♪
♪ Way down in Egypt's land ♪
♪ Tell old Pharaoh ♪
♪ Let My people go ♪
♪ Go down Moses ♪
♪ Way down in Egypt's land ♪
♪ Tell old Pharaoh ♪
♪ Let My people go ♪
- And at last, Pharaoh
released the Jews from bondage.
♪ Let My people go ♪
(gentle piano music)
- Let My people go.
In that simple phrase, lies the
universal truth of Passover.
It's no exaggeration to
say that the Exodus story
is one of the most important
narratives in the history of the world.
Forget the fact that it's
survived thousands of years,
this is a story that if
you take into account,
Islam and Christianity has
deep, meaningful significance
for half the population of the planet,
and yet it's allegorical significance
transcends the Abrahamic faiths.
It transcends Judaism.
In fact, it transcends religion.
That's because all of us,
no matter who we are
or what God we worship,
can identify with the longing
to be free from oppression,
the feeling of dispossession and exile,
the dream of liberation,
the yearning for home,
however it's defined.
The story of Exodus is
the story of the movement
from oppression to freedom,
and that's something every
one of us can connect with.
(upbeat music)
- Hello everyone, Tan France here
ready to help our little Sinai
Cinderella as she crosses
that Red Sea and wanders
the desert for 40 years.
I'm thinking like lightweight
and Daphne coffin based.
Just because you're
pleading girls not wean,
you can't be dazzling.
- Just a current fact.
- Herringbone scarf.
- Did you say 40 years?
- Before I forget, I wanna
mention one other thing,
you're gonna collapse at some point
that you are gonna fall
to that desert floor.
- Come again?
- When you do, you're gonna
wanna look fab, not drab,
you do not wanna be scabbed, hand shoes.
Hand shoes are shoes for your hands.
You're gonna wanna probably
go for like a wedge
so that when the elbow hits,
it's gonna look so stylized,
so elongated, so chic.
- I don't have a wedge, I have these guys,
I'm gonna put them on my hands
and the hands shoes, got it.
- They're not really what
I was thinking you do.
- When you say 40 years,
that's metaphorical, right?
- I think you're gonna be just fine.
- I'm I ready?
- Gorgeous.
- [Beanie] Thanks Tim.
- My favorite part of Passover
is everyone gathering around
to sing some of their favorite songs.
My family, we did Passover
Broadway parody songs.
Hope you enjoy a few little tastes.
♪ Into the sea where Adonai has
promise that the land is dry ♪
♪ Moses is here and he's the guy ♪
♪ To guide us on our journey ♪
Or
♪ Goodbye goodbye Mitzrayim ♪
♪ Mitzrayim Mitzrayim goodbye ♪
♪ We're sick of building the pyramids ♪
♪ Losing our firstborn kids ♪
♪ Sing Mitzrayim goodbye ♪
And of course,
♪ Bang a drum spread the news ♪
♪ Things are looking
real good for the Jews ♪
♪ We've escaped we're alive ♪
♪ And now everything's coming up Moses ♪
But of course we can't forget
♪ Master of the Jews giving us a push ♪
♪ Sure that God is hiding
in a burning bush ♪
♪ Here another frog there a little lice ♪
♪ Thinking Pharaoh's
gonna follow his advice ♪
♪ If we do as Moses tells us ♪
♪ All of us will surely lose ♪
♪ Heading to disaster following
the master of the Jews ♪
- [Announcer] To obtain your copy of
Now that's what I call Passover,
donate to the CDC Foundation today.
(upbeat music)
- All right, I hope
you found the Afikoman.
It should have been a pretty easy hunt
as I literally gave you the answer, right?
It turns out my sense of fun
is not shared by everybody.
Usually if you find the
Afikoman, you get money,
which means there's a beloved tradition
at every single Passover
for all the children,
but one, to cry and get really pissed off
because they didn't locate a
hidden piece of magic matzah
that would net them a nickel.
Isaac, did you ever find the Afikoman?
- Never once, Andy.
And actually if you know what this year,
I think it's a better idea, instead of
expecting to get any
money from the Afikoman,
how about giving some
money, lending a hand?
- I like it.
You're suggesting a little guilt.
Okay, I'm gonna join in.
While we're at it, people,
why haven't you called your grandfather?
- Thank you, and are you showering?
- Have you clicked the link?
Have you?
- Have you donated to the CDC?
- What are you doing for Mother's Day?
- And, are you dating anyone?
'Cause she's gonna wanna know.
- And are you actually dating
them or just like dating them?
- You miss the guilt, don't you?
You do, so a good way to
alleviate the guilt is donate.
- The CDC foundation is
doing everything it can
to meet the many needs that arise
during the COVID-19 pandemic response.
Protection, detection,
providing personal protective
equipment, deploying
emergency staff, everything.
- Support them, okay?
- And not to guilt you or anything,
but it's the least you could do.
- At our Passover Seders,
we traditionally describe
an All powerful God
who rescued our ancestors from slavery.
But the actual story in the Bible
includes a number of
human characters as well.
A pair of midwives who refused
to obey Pharaoh's order
to kill all Israelite babies
and safely deliver baby Moses,
Pharaoh's daughter who rescues
Moses knowing full well
that he's an Israelite
baby and has the audacity
to raise him in her father's palace,
breaking his law right under his nose.
And Moses himself, who despite
his fears and self doubt,
answers the calls to rescue his people.
This is exactly the kind
of courage and compassion
we're seeing right now
in medical professionals,
grocery workers, and so many others
risking their lives on our behalf.
This Passover, we honor the
stories of our ancestors
by honoring the sacrifices
of these heroes.
(whimsical piano music)
- So now,
standing at the edge of the sea.
- Everywhere you look is water.
- And at the distance, you hear your enemy
and they're making their way towards you.
- You feel a surge of panic.
- I mean, people are saying,
you're about to be free.
What, free?
What does that even mean?
- You don't know?
- You don't know what to believe.
- In front of you, only the water.
- And behind you, the enemy is closing in.
- All your life, you've
never known freedom.
- There has never been
a day when you woke up
and your life was your own.
- This is what's on your mind
as the enemy gets closer.
- And suddenly,
the water begins to shift.
- Move.
- To part.
- Like nothing you have ever seen.
- I mean, how knew that
there were such things
as miracles on this earth?
- Scared to take each step,
you fight against your
instincts and you cross.
- And somehow,
Somehow, you make it to the other side.
- Exhilarated!
- Terrified.
- Everything you were,
the person you have been
is back there.
- And all you know
right now is that today,
you witnessed a miracle.
- And that miracle sets you free.
(gentle piano music)
♪ Many nights we prayed ♪
♪ With no proof anyone could hear ♪
♪ In our hearts a hopeful song ♪
♪ We barely understood ♪
♪ Now we are not afraid ♪
♪ Although we know there's much to fear ♪
♪ We were moving mountains long ♪
♪ Before we knew we could ♪
♪ There can be miracles ♪
♪ When you believe ♪
♪ Though hope is frail it's hard to kill ♪
♪ Who knows what miracles ♪
♪ You can achieve ♪
♪ When you believe somehow you will ♪
♪ You will when you believe ♪
♪ In this time of fear ♪
♪ When prayer so often proves in vain ♪
♪ Hope seems like the summer birds ♪
♪ Too swiftly flown away ♪
♪ Yet now I'm standing here ♪
♪ My heart so full I cant explain ♪
♪ Seeking faith and speaking words ♪
♪ I never thought I'd say ♪
♪ There can be miracles when you believe ♪
♪ When you believe ♪
♪ Though hope is frail it's hard to kill ♪
♪ Who knows what miracles
you can achieve ♪
♪ You can achieve ♪
♪ When you believe somehow you will ♪
♪ You will when you believe ♪
♪ They don't always happen when you ask ♪
♪ And it's easy to give in to your fears ♪
♪ But when you're blinded by your pain ♪
♪ Can't see your way
clear through the rain ♪
♪ A small but still resilient voice ♪
♪ Says help is very near ♪
♪ There can be miracles ♪
♪ Miracles ♪
♪ When you believe ♪
♪ Though hope is frail ♪
♪ It's hard to kill ♪
♪ Who knows what miracles ♪
♪ You can achieve ♪
♪ When you believe ♪
♪ Somehow you will ♪
♪ Somehow somehow somehow ♪
♪ Somehow somehow you will ♪
♪ When you believe ♪
♪ You will when you believe ♪
♪ Believe ♪
- Happy Passover everyone,
stay healthy and safe.
- Holy mother of Pesach!
That was gorgeous.
- I mean, Holy Macaroni,
that was beautiful!
- That was so moving, it hurts
and it's not just
because I've been staring
at my belly button for hours
on end every day (bleeps)
(speaks in foreign language)
- Okay, at this point,
your family is rushing
through the (mumbles) to get to the food.
- Keep your eye on the prize, Jews.
Follow through, that potato
kugel is nearly yours.
- Damn!
Spa daya!
COVID-19.
Ronna Clickman here
urging you all to include
an 11th plague in USAID this year.
Click the button to donate
to the CDC Foundation
and enjoy your Passover, the
only holiday where you are
commanded to drink four glasses of wine.
I'm enjoying a beautiful
argentine cappuccino.
May your manicures all
hold up in quarantine
as nicely as mine has, cheers, cheers.
- Well, hi everybody.
this is Senator Chuck
Schumer on Passover Night
and some have joke that you
can distill the Haggadah
and all Jewish holidays
into three simple sentences.
They tried to kill us,
we survived, let's eat.
During this Passover with the coronavirus,
unfortunately, those words are no joke,
they are all reality.
But I know how many of us feel isolated
and uncertain about the
future, frightened right now.
But we Jews know the
power of perseverance,
that's how we've survived
over the centuries.
Sticking together, giving
each other strength
and moral support and
overcoming the worst,
the worst of afflictions and persecutions.
So, together we will overcome this plague
like everyone before it, so
that we can be happy, healthy,
free once again, and we
can have our next Seder,
maybe not in Jerusalem, but all together
with our family and friends.
To all of you, a decent Pesach.
- Yeah, it's Passover, yes!
- Passover is a journey,
a journey within where we pull
back the layers of our soul,
we look inwards.
- What you realize from this
communal holiday is that--
- We all are alike.
- It doesn't matter where
you're from or what you do,
how much you know.
- Rituals may change, the
language and methods of observance
may change but--
- The beliefs and what we
share and what we hold dear
to one another, our families,
our annoying relatives
who wanna constantly question
who is in our love life
and who isn't.
- We're all the same, we're all connected.
Each and every one of us is holy,
is connected to our creator.
- But ultimately, Jews are just people
who want to get together,
just sit in solid silence,
just waiting for someone to finish talking
so they can get some food in their faces.
- And through that together,
experiencing that unity as individuals
or experiences as a people and as a world
and bring goodness for
each and every one of us
in our lives.
- Happy Passover.
(gentle piano music)
- I'm taken back to a story
that is thousands of years old.
This story that we told tonight,
a story that's held a grip
on the human imagination
for thousands of years.
Precisely because it was never just about
what happened then, but
has also always been about
what's happening now.
It's never been just about
what happened to them,
but it's always been about
what's also happening to us.
This is a story of an Israelite people
who were degraded and
oppressed and enslaved,
and then somehow through
the series of miracles,
both divine and human, were able to begin
to walk on that long
journey toward freedom.
This is a story in the
language of our Rabbis,
(speaks in foreign language)
of a trajectory that takes
us from darkness to light.
(speaks in foreign language)
From anguish to joy, from
grief to celebration,
from narrowness to great expansiveness,
from degradation to dignity.
And our rabbis understood
that that was a message
that we needed to hear not only once,
but needed to be built into our DNA
so that we would have the
muscle memory for hope
exactly in moments like the
ones we're living in right now,
when we need hope the most.
In fact, this story is
the closest thing we have
to the genetic transmission of hope
because it tells us that even
though things are painful
and hard, and we are incredibly
vulnerable right now,
that we will survive this,
that our story doesn't end here
and that we, like those who
came before us, will one day
come to the other side of
this plague of darkness.
And when we do, we will grieve
and then we will rebuild.
And I pray on this night
that we will do what the
Israelites did so many years ago.
They rebuilt a society
that was the counter Egypt,
that was the antithesis
of what they'd experienced
in their suffering in Egypt.
And we will build a
society that is counter
to the injustices and oppressions
and indignities of this
world that we have lived in.
And instead we'll build
a world rooted in justice
and equity and equality
and dignity for all people
and most of all, in love.
And that will be a beautiful
world for all of us.
- Hey, we can't thank you
enough for joining us.
And with that, our Passover
Seder is about to come--
- Actually, sorry, I have
a couple of questions.
- Yes, Josh Groban everyone the best
non-Jewish voice since Bobby Darin.
- Thank you, this has been so great,
thank you so much for having me.
But I was wondering what's Had Gadya?
- Yeah, Had Gadya, I was
wondering about that as well.
- Who told you guys about Had Gadya?
- Dude, come on, we all
know about Had Gadya.
- It's rocking, I sing it
every time I play Tel Aviv.
- All right, very good, guys.
So--
- Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, hang on seriously.
what about the leaning?
Can we talk about all that, the leaning?
Where did that go?
- Yeah, the four sons, the
matzah sandwich, come on.
- And you're seriously not
gonna open the door for Elijah?
- How do you guys know
so much about Passover?
- Tevye in high school.
- No way, I was Tevye in high school too,
that's amazing, and I love Mitzrayim.
- Take a wild guess.
So, how about the Afikoman?
- Well, we're not opening the doors
for strangers right now, Rachel.
But when you're right, you're right, yes.
Let's find out who found the Afikoman.
- What the actual,
oh my God!
Oh my God, I found the Afikomen.
I found the Afikomen!
It was inside my (bleeps)
Oh my gosh, I knew it was
inside me the whole time.
(upbeat music)
- Hi everybody, happy Pesach.
It's me Elijah, I'm so happy to see you.
Were you expecting somebody else?
A man maybe?
Yeah, that happens to me a lot.
Please, nobody but me could
pull off a schedule like this.
Now, for those of you out
there who don't know me,
I'm kind of like Santa Claus.
But my people deliver me glasses of wine
instead of cookies and milk.
And my only gift to them is wisdom.
I do wanna say though, to
all my friends out there
who've been so kind over
the years, ply me with wine
and Moror and charoset and all that,
I've been sober for about 300 years.
So next year, a few granola
bars would be just fine.
Well anyway, I just wanna
say I know you might be
having a tough time out
there all by yourselves,
maybe goin' a little bit stir-crazy,
yes, maybe scary, but listen,
I have to visit 2 million homes a night
and that is very, very scary too,
and it's not good social distancing.
So stay in, just wanna say
stay in, wash your hands,
be kind, be good to each other.
Mostly, be good to each other.
Elijah (mumbles)
- Next year in Jerusalem.
As a kid, those are always my
favorite words at the Seder
because they meant it was almost over
and time for dessert,
macaroons, pineapple slices,
and our noodle pudding
topped with candy cherries.
As I grew into the age of knowing it all,
I began to question
next year in Jerusalem.
I mean, why would anyone
wanna go to Jerusalem?
It's hot, you're surrounded
by a vast majority of the
dissect mite and all the cute
soldiers in uniform are girls.
Made no sense to me that Jews
would want to go to Israel.
I know it has sand, that you can pick up
a quick Marshawn game,
but Miami, it ain't.
Still after everything Jews
went through in the Holocaust,
when asked whether they
wanted to make their Homeland,
they picked Jerusalem.
You want proof that it's a bad idea?
Jared Kushner thinks it's a good idea.
I rest my case.
If it was me, I would've
sent (bleeps) to the Germans
and take it Berlin.
Can you imagine Berlin
is the Jewish Homeland,
beautiful architecture,
museums, centrally located
to all the other
wonderful European cities.
What's Jerusalem, near the Dead Sea?
That's like people
spending their life savings
to go to Las Vegas and
staying at the Luxor Hotel.
Chianti, where should we go on vacation?
I know, let's go stay in a big black tomb.
And so, I spent my years of enlightenment
shaking my head whenever my
father read out those words,
Next year in Jerusalem.
So, now I'm old.
I'm with age, comes
irritable bowels and wisdom.
Unless of course you're a white Christian,
heterosexual man in fly over country
and instead of wisdom, you get
gas and scratch off tickets.
I now realize that all of religion
can be taken with a grain of salt
and adapted to whatever belief system
to what you wish to subscribe.
And so, that phrase has no meaning to me.
Next year in Jerusalem, to me means,
next year, we will be in our home
and that home will be
a world without fear,
a world without hunger, a world
without poverty and worked.
Next year, we will be in a world
that is caring and supportive
of it's inhabitants
and a world where it's inhabitants
are caring and supportive of
the world in which they live.
Next year, we will look to
our great minds for leadership
and execute out mouthfuls.
Next year, we will remember
the lessons of kindness
from our youth.
Next year, we will aspire
to live our possibilities.
Next year, we will be grateful
for the gift of life we've been given.
Next year, we will achieve
our goals and share our bounty
with family, friends, and neighbors.
Next year, the word
stranger will be meaningless
because next year, we will
all be together in our home.
So, Next year in Jerusalem.
Now, serve the sponge cake.
(gentle piano music)
♪ When the walls have grown narrow ♪
♪ When the world has turned gray ♪
♪ And headlines are here
rolling day after day ♪
♪ As you wander and wonder
how long you'll stay lost ♪
♪ Remember the oceans and deserts ♪
♪ We've already crossed ♪
♪ 'Cause next next year ♪
♪ The doors will break open next year ♪
♪ Next year we'll breathe in the sky ♪
♪ For tomorrow is uncertain ♪
♪ We're gonna get by so it's you ♪
♪ So here is to next year ♪
♪ Next year ♪
♪ Here's to next year ♪
♪ And when the people are pleading ♪
♪ 'Cause the day seem so sad ♪
♪ And where there's nobody
leading you (mumbles) ♪
♪ Out of the dark ♪
♪ Can't let the misery harden your heart ♪
♪ The worst will pass over ♪
♪ And one day the waters will pass ♪
♪ 'Cause next year next year ♪
♪ The world will break open next year ♪
♪ Next year we'll breathe in the sky ♪
♪ Though tomorrow is uncertain ♪
♪ We gonna get by till it's here ♪
♪ So here is to next year to next year ♪
♪ Here's to next year ♪
♪ Next year next year ♪
- Next year, hugging and kissing
every single person I've
ever loved in my entire life.
- Next year, everywhere in the world.
- Next year in Jerusalem,
all of us in good health
- Next year, not here.
- Next year, we will be on vacation.
- To Hawaii.
- With friends.
- And family.
- And family, oh sure.
- Why are you copying me?
- Next year in a more fair country.
- Next year with our
families and chosen families.
(speaks in foreign language)
- Next year in a real democracy.
- Next year in a theater with all of you.
- I'm gonna say next year
at my boyfriend's house
I'm looking for a man, a nice man.
- Next year, performing for
everyone in the same room.
- Next year.
- With her grandparents.
- Next year holding hands.
- Next year, I wanna be surrounded
by even more of my Jewish
brothers and sisters.
- Next year with hugs
and kisses with family.
- Next year in my mom's
kitchen in Long Island.
- Next year by Lake Michigan
in Chicago with my family.
- Next year, mask free,
drinking gin and tonics.
♪ Next year next year ♪
- Next year in health, at
peace, with family, at home.
♪ Next year ♪
♪ Don't ever break the old plans ♪
♪ We'll break into the sky ♪
♪ Next year it's gonna be better ♪
♪ As you wander and wonder ♪
♪ How long you'll stay lost ♪
♪ Remember the oceans and deserts ♪
♪ We've already crossed ♪
- Good night everybody,
stay safe, stay healthy, stay inside.
Next year in Jerusalem, God bless.
(soft guitar music)
♪ (sings in foreign language) ♪
♪ Old grandpa went to market once ♪
♪ To see what he could buy ♪
♪ He bought us snow white kit ♪
♪ Because it's cold and cow dessert ♪
♪ The greedy cat within our valley hid ♪
♪ And then choked out
with winter clothes ♪
♪ He scud our little kid ♪
♪ (sings in foreign language) ♪
♪ The dog was angry with the cat ♪
♪ For doing such a deed ♪
♪ He lived up on the frightened cat ♪
♪ He slew him with great speed ♪
♪ The stick was very angry that that ♪
♪ I lift up from his cliff ♪
♪ He picked her dog upon her head ♪
♪ And even in the face ♪
(child grunting happily)
(laughing)
(TV announcer chattering)